a deadly gang war is being waged on
Sweden's streets and the country's
police said prime minister ol
Christenson are overwhelmed it is time
he said to summon Military
Support we have an increased level of
Terror right now in Sweden the police
cannot do all the work against Crime
themselves the armed forces have special
abilities to support the police within
the current law such as Logistics and
intelligence gathering as well as
competence in assessing future risks and
targets the Prime Minister also said he
will Deport any foreigners involved in
criminal gangs military involvement in
crime fighting is a highly unusual step
for Sweden a sign of how challenging
things have become for regular law
enforcement it follows the killing of
two people in separate shootings in
Stockholm on Wednesday and a woman in
her 20s thought to be an innocent
bystander died when a bomb tore through
a house in the city of obala in the
early hours of Thursday also this week
two powerful explosions ripped through
homes in central Sweden injuring at
least three people the deadly crime
waves claimed 11 lives this month
including a 13-year-old boy who was
found shot in the head in Woodland close
to his home near Stockholm during the
last years we have seen um a an
increasing that young boys and children
are getting involved in the criminal
gangs um one of the reason that children
and young boys are actually involved and
that they are trying to focus on them is
that the children and the young boys are
really good in working and working with
the drug uh the drug Market that the
gangs are focus on the latest surging
killings has been linked to a feud
between rival factions of a criminal
gang known as foxtrot in a country where
police estimate as many as 30,000 people
are directly involved or have ties to
gang crime Neve Parker Al jazer
after 27 years a man
has make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz